so when I decided to take a look at what
websites had a slow layout
I came to nbcnews.com this website has
different stories laid out in sort of a
grid on the screen let's see what
happens if we change the size of the
grid we can see that the stories instead
of being stacked next to each other are
now stacked on top of each other let's
make this fullscreen again
and we can see that the stories moved
out to their original horizontal
orientation let's take a look at what
this looks like in dev tools I'll press
command option I to open up dev tools
alright where I have the HTML let's go
over to the timeline and I'm gonna hit
the record button and start changing the
size of the screen and watching what
happens with layout
we'll make it small okay it looks like
the stories have moved let me go ahead
and make it fullscreen again cool and I
can go ahead and stop the recording all
right so we have quite a bit of data
here in the timeline I'm not sure what
exactly we need to look at so let's go
ahead and while instead of searching
through just filter out what we don't
want lay-up happens in rendering so
let's get rid of painting scripting and
loading we only see these purple events
here let's go ahead and take a look at
this section we can see a few layout
events clicking on this one we can see
that it took 113 milliseconds which is
definitely a noticeable amount of time